التشويش الالكتروني. فضلا عن
تزويدها بمحركات تزيد بشكل ملموس
حديثة. برأيكم هل البجعة البيضاء
هي من ضمن الاسلحة الحديثة التي
امكانيات جديدة اتاحت لها الحصول
على معدات ملاحة الكترونية جديدة
وعشرين. لاستعراض الصناعات
العسكرية الروسية. وبحضور اثنتين
المقاتلات لحمايتها. ولذلك
اشتملت عمليات التحديث على طلاء
العسكري. في عهد بوتين. كل شيء
يخطط له يسير بكل جدية واحترافي.
التحديث الكامل. حصلت نسختها
المتطورة والاستراتيجية على
تكنولوجيا ستيلت او الشبح اي عدم
القدرة على التخفي. حيث ترافقها
المحركات الى الولايات المتحدة
من باب السرية العسكرية. التحديث
الاستراتيجية الروسية ودورة
الوقود فيها وازدادوا قناعة بان
محرك والروسي افضل من محركات
طائراتهم الاستراتيجية بي وان
بالمحرك الخاص بطائرة تيو وان
سيكستي. وتم ذلك لتقوم الطائرة
ينسى ابن الكريملين تحديث انظمة
القاذفة الاستراتيجية الشهيرة.
ثمانين دولة اعلن بوتين ان بلاده
تقدر علاقاتها مع دول في امريكا
ايه وبي ون بي. ولم يتمكن
الامريكيون من تحقيق بشكل كامل
كليا مضادة للنيترونات
والاشعاعات النووية. وانظمة تحكم
اللاتينية واسيا وافريقيا وانها
مستعدة لتزويد حلفائها باسلحة
ضرورة تزويد النموذج التجريبي من
الطائرة الروسية الامريكية
الامريكيون خلالها من الاطلاع
على مواصفات محرك الطائرة
روسيا المرعب. امريكا امام
الاسطورة الروسية. بدافع الفضول
الفين وخمسة عشر اتخذت روسيا
قرارها باعادة انتاجها وكسرت
طنا. وهذا ما يسمح لها بالطيران
المتواصل لمدة خمس عشرة ساعة.
الامريكيون ان يفحصوا هذه
الطائرة للتوصل الى معرفة ما اذا
وعلى رأسها تيو وان سيكسي. قبل
عمليات التحديث كانت تشير العديد
يو ون سيكسي تتفوق على جميع
الطائرات الاستراتيجية الامريكية
من التقارير الى ان الشيء الوحيد
الذي تفتقده هذه القاذفة هو
كانت تملك القدرات المعلنة عنها
بالفعل ام لا. وفعلا اتيحت لهم
التجريبية بثلاثين رحلة جوية
اختبارية تمكن الخبراء
شدة الانفجار. باختصار يصنفها
الخبراء العسكريون انها وجه
الحاجة للتزود بالوقود. وفي عام
الفين واثنين وعشرين بادرت روسيا
كان متوقعا. ثانيا امتنعت روسيا
عن تسليم تكنولوجيا صناعة
وكي لا يتقدم عليه منافسوه بخطوة
واحدة. وفي سباقه مع الزمن لم
الماضي ووجدوا حينذاك صدمة
صناعية تحبس الانفاس. فطائرة تي
تيو وان سيكستي وحاولوا تحقيق
مرادهم من خلال مشروع طائرة
نوويتين من على سطح البحر لتصحو
الدول المجاورة على هول فاجعة من
من فعاليتها القتالية لاديمير
بوتين. وبالتحديد في موسكو. وفي
ورادارات جديدة وانظمة متطورة
للحرب الالكترونية والتعامل مع
الطائرة بمواد خاصة تجعل منها
غير مرئية من قبل الرادارات وبعد
ومن اجل تكذيب الاسطورة ووضعها
امام موقف محرج. طلب الخبراء
وبالاخص في مجال المحركات. واراد
الامريكيون ان يحصلوا على محرك
فرصة التعرف بالبجاعة البيضاء
الروسية وذلك في تسعينات القرن
باول تجربة نووية البيضاء لتحلق
فوق القطب الشمالي وتطلق قذيفتين
الركاب الاسرع كثيرا من الصوت
الروسية الامريكية. واصروا على
ومن ابرز عمليات تحديثه للسلاح
الروسي كي يواكب العالم المعاصر
لسببين اولهما ان الطائرة
الروسية الامريكية لم تكن كما
وزنها فارغة مائة وعشرة اطنان.
ووزنها عند الاقلاع مائتان وخمسة
البيضاء. فليس كل من يمتلك
جناحين ابيضين هو ملاك بريء فمن
الزوايا تمكن كابتن الطائرة من
التحكم في انحناء الجناحين من
متر مربع. انتج منها خمس وثلاثون
طائرة في عام الفين. وفي عام
الى خمس وستين درجة. تمتلك اربعة
محركات نفاثة وخاصية التزود
بالوقود اثناء الطيران وتمتلك
خزان وقود يتسع لمئة وثلاثين
تحت هذه الاجنحة تستطيع اطلاق
اثني عشر صاروخا نوويا وهي قادرة
رقما قياسيا مرعبا. حيث حلقت
ثمانية عشر الف كيلو متر دون
فعاليات منتدى الجيش التقني
الدولي لعام الفين واثنين
مترا ووزن الاقلاع مائتين وخمسة
وسبعين طنا. رغم كبر حجمها فان
وسبعون طنا. اما طولها يصل لخمسة
وخمسين ومساحة الاجنحة اربعمائة
بسرعة تفوق سرعة الصوت. بجاعة
الموت الابيض لها اجنحة متعددة
تتغنى موسكو بصناعتها لهذا الرعب
الجوي. بفضل لونها وشكلها اكتسبت
واحد لن تجد منه الا ذرات رماده.
ما كل هذه الشراسة الحربية لم
اسم الموت او البجاعة البيضاء.
هي من اكبر واثقل الطائرات
ننتهي بعد يا صديقي. فالرعب
الاكبر يسكن اسفل اجنحتها
كذلك على حمل اربعة وعشرين مجنحا
من طراز وتطير هذه الصواريخ
اي انها اذا اسقطت هذا الكم
الهائل من المتفجرات على هدف
محركاتها النفاذة تجعل سرعة
البجعة اسرع من الصوت. حيث تصل
طائرة عادية بل انها ثكنة عسكرية
او منصة اطلاق نووي. يقال عنها
القتالية في العالم. حيث يبلغ
طول جناحها اكثر من خمسة وخمسين
الى الفين ومائتي كيلو متر في
الساعة. ومداها سبعة الاف مائة
كيلومتر هي قادرة على اسقاط
اربعين طنا من القنابل المتفجرة
طائرة بوتين المدللة اذ لطالما
تباهى بها بوتين واشار باصبعه
اطلاق اثني عشر صاروخا نوويا.
بجاعة الموت الروسية. دائما ما
الاقمار الصناعية ولها غرفة
عمليات جوية متخصصة قادرة على
الف وتسعمائة وسبعة وثمانين. حيث
دخلت القاذفة الروسية الخدمة في
الموت نتحدث وللقصة بقية. تاريخ
ميلاد هذه الطائرة كان في عام
هذا العام تحمل في جوفها اربعين
طنا من الذخائر وتحرك عبر
اليها. فهي الكابوس الذي يسرق
النوم من اعين الاعداء. عن بجاعة
وتحول المدن الى صحارى. تمتلك
شراسة تدميرية غير عادية هي ليست
زر تسقط اربعين طنا من المتفجرات
على هدف واحد. تقتل الملايين
تنتمي له. لانها تطلق اثني عشر
صاروخا نوويا دفعة واحدة وبضغطة
البيضاء في الجو لا تسمع اصوات
محركاتها ودخان الموت يداعب
مدافعها التي تختبئ تحت اجنحتها.
تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت. اذا
وجدتها في السماء فلتوقن ان
المعركة انتهت لصالح الطرف الذي
قاذفة جهنم او الموت الابيض
والمعروفة عالميا باسم البجاعة
سيزود بها بوتين حلفاءه حول
العالم?